deux conseillers généraux sortant en
duel c'est le résultat du premier tour
des élections départementales 2015 pour
le canton de morpa avec 41,12 % le duo
Rosetti vanval une union umpudi récolte
le plus de voix largement tête devant le
binôme pS je pense que c'était une
stratégie nécessaire les gens ne
comprennent pas les divisions de la
droite surtout à l'échelon local où rien
ne les justifie et par conséquent
effectivement je crois que ça a été une
stratégie intelligente rationnelle pour
gérer au mieux et continuer de bien
gérer le département des ivelines le
Parti socialiste lui n'a pas fait
d'alliance pour ses élections avec un
score de 22,27 % sur les 16 communes du
canton Ismaël avan conseiller général
sortant élu à morpa en 2008 garde espoir
pour le second tour ma candidature en
tant que conseiller général sortant a
vocation de
rassembler toutes les forces qui ont
vocation à adhérer à notre à notre
projet mais au-delà de ça nous on a axé
notre campagne sur le local sur le bilan
qu'on a qu'on a produit qui est qui est
un bon bilan donc on invite tous les
morpasiennes tous les morpasiens tous
les habitants de ce du canton de morpas
à se rejoindre pour créer une dynamique
pour le second tour du côté de l'UMP udi
on appelle également à la mobilisation
des électeurs le binôme union de la
droite affirme que rien n'est gagné pour
le second tour malgré des résultats
conséquents comme sur la commune de
voisin le Bretonneux où le duo a
remporté 52,17 % des suffrages exprimés
les candidats s'inquiètent des résultats
du binôme du Front national le FN
talonne le binôme PS et remporte 17,39 %
des suffrages sur le canton quand on
voit les candidats qui ont été présenté
dont on ne sait absolument rien dont on
avait même pas la photo des suppléants
on sait pas où ils habitent on ne sait
je suis un peu inquiète de me dire qu'on
puisse voter pour pour des inconnus et
en même temps ça veut bien dire que il y
a un message qui est passé au politique
aujourd'hui donc sur la commune de
toussul Le Noble le binô Front national
arrive second avec 23,22 % des suffrage
exprimé derrière l'Union de la Droite
dans le conton de morpa socialiste avant
son redécoupage l'année dernière le
Front national ne compte que 44 voix de
moins que le binôme van Mercier moi je
suis relativement satisfait vraiment
satisfait parce que le but Ctait
vraiment de se rapprocher le plus
possible du PS on savait que c'était
suivant le découpage un canton assez
difficile pour Front national
l'argumentaire de Marie
et et sa pédagogie sa manière
d'expliquer les choses sont vraiment
très importantes et nous aideent
forcément ici aussi à morpa le tandem
divers droite sans étiquette politique
se classe lui en 4e position il récolte
10,59 % des voix et dresse une analyse
en demi-teinte de ce premier tour nous
avions adopté une démarche assez
originale hein puisque on était chapauté
par aucune étiquette politique donc
c'est quand même c'est quand même c'est
quand même ambitieux comme on dit
c'était aussi extrêmement risqué
55% d'abstention c'est énorme c'est
décevant deuxèmement il y a une forte
poussée de l'extrême droite du Front
national c'est énorme c'est décevant pas
de consigne de vote au second tour pour
le binôme divers droite comme le Front
de gauche qui enregistre 8,63 % des
voies il laisse les électeurs voter en
leur amé conscience nous on s'est engagé
contre une politique d'économie libérale
donc on va rester sur cette logique
là 51 % des électeurs du canton ne se
sont pas déplacés ce dimanche un
réservoir d'abstentionniste qui reste à
convaincre avant le 29 mars pour les
deux binôes en
LCE